One way to solve the problem is to simply stop using the
mutext lock on the while statement. This sets off something called the sync
race where one thread is quickly reading a variable and a while loop,
or spinning on it, as it waits for another thread to change the
value of a variable. Because the spinning thread is just checking the
valuable of a variable over and over. It can't possibly interfere with anything
the other thread is doing. So we can be reasonably confident this is
correct. This turns out to be a fine way for threads to communicate,
this sync race, that is. Actually, if
this spinning thread has its own processor or
core to run on, then it will resume its execution very quickly, which can be
a good thing. However, if processing time
is at premium, then all this spinning is
just wasted. Hence the motivation for another
important feature of thread libraries, conditional wait variables.